du côté d'ottawa on s'est beaucoup
interrogé sur l'avenir de thomas mulcair
et de gilles duceppe à la tête de leurs
formations respectives après la victoire
libérale de lundi danielle thibeault le
chef du bloc québécois doit donner une
conférence de presse demain mais on sait
maintenant ce qu'il va annoncer
voilà c'est les nymphettes selon nos
sources ce monsieur duceppe annoncera
demain qu'il quitte la tête du bloc
québécois pour une deuxième fois donc il
fera cette annonce après avoir rencontré
les membres du bureau national du bloc
québécois demain matin de même que les
candidats qui étaient qui sont présentés
à l'élection de lundi ce sera fait à la
permanence du bloc
c'est donc monsieur duceppe qui va mener
les destinées des dix nouveaux députés
du bloc à ottawa
on devrait aussi annoncer demain que
c'est catherine fournier qui apprendra
la présidence du bloc québécois à la
place de mario beaulieu qui lui est
maintenant élu madame fournier jeune
femme de 23 ans est candidate dans
montarville elle a été défaite on
voudrait en la nommant à ce poste une
nouvelle image de la formation politique
madame fournier n'a pas voulu confirmer
cette information là mais quand on lui a
parlé un peu plus tôt d'un poignet nom
auquel en plus de détails demain donc
justin trudeau lui s'installe lentement
dans son nouveau fauteuil de premier
ministre a discuté de transition
aujourd'hui avec stephen rapp voilà
fallait que ça arrive cette rencontre
l'aca lieu ce après midi entre stephen
harper le premier ministre sortant et
justin trudeau premier ministre désigné
dans les bureaux du premier ministre
l'édifice langevin est tout près d'ici
une rencontre d'une trentaine de minutes
comme monsieur trudeau est arrivé mais
sur un peu étaient déjà là du côté entre
libéral on parle d'une rencontre
positive et généreuse
ce sera la seule rencontre entre les
deux hommes le reste se fera au niveau
du conseil privé
et puis on sait maintenant qui va
s'occuper de la transition pour justin
trudeau
c'est un homme du nom de peter gunn
l'ancien haut-fonctionnaire sous
ministre dans plusieurs ministères qui a
travaillé sous les libéraux sous les
conservateurs aussi un homme hautement
respecté de la fonction publique ce que
ça envoie comme signal ça c'est qu'on
fait confiance à la fonction publique et
qu'on veut remettre l'appareil
gouvernemental au travail rapidement
monsieur radio s'est donné un échéancier
serré quand même il veut un conseil des
ministres d'ici le 4 novembre
et là on veut qu'ils aient sous ministre
mette au travail et qu'on prépare les
dossiers qu'on transforme le programme
libre
un agenda législatif et consomme est
probablement tout de suite à la
rédaction des premiers projets de loi
qui seront présentés dès le retour en
chambres du parlement et daniel de même
un terrien ils vont se rencontrer demain
la justin trudeau
voilà c'est ça monsieur rappeur mc
trudeau qui vont se rencontrer demain
matin une rencontre un peu plus formel
cela lors des cérémonies de
commémoration des attaques sur le
parlement du 22 octobre de l'année
dernière donc cérémonies auxquelles les
deux hommes ont participé
très bien merci daniel au plaisir